[Music]  Stand Down  Jesse stand down that's in order  foreign  [Applause]  s came pouring over the 38th parallel  This Is War and we're up  we know this day might come it doesn't  make it any easier  [Music]  the commanding officer called you one of  the best Pilots he's ever seen  the Naval aviator it's the toughest job  there is you don't think that you'd be  in a squadron with a colored Aviator  can't take it how many times people have  told me to give up quick  not even  that's why you can't always do what  you're told what do you want me to do  just be modeling man you belong in this  guy Jesse  remember you belong down here with us  too okay  I need everyone sharp and ready  boys are Holding On by their fingernail  s we bring everyone home  [Music]  and then what'd you fighting for  [Applause]  the show off that was pretty good it's  good  thank you